Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Linus. Guten Morgen Tim.
Wir haben es wieder einmal äh geschafft, die siebzehnte Ausgabe von Lokbuchen Netzpolitik steht an, für euch zum,
Faulenzen äh vor dem Netz gerät
Ihr könnt euch jetzt wieder alles anhören, was alles so passiert ist und äh ja, es ist mal wieder so einiges passiert und wir haben
auch heute noch ein kleines Spezial äh geplant für diese Sendung und zwar wollen wir uns mal ganz besonders die Situation in Österreich anschauen, die wir bisher mangels Wissens immer schriftlich vernachlässigt haben
begrüßen dazu auch einen Gast, nämlich den Thomas, Thomas Luninger, hallo.
Hallo, grüß dich Tim.
Thomas, äh, kurz zu dir, du bist, ähm, ja, weiß nicht, so ein bisschen über die, die kulturelle Schiene, äh, glaube ich, so in das Ganze,
netzpolitische Geschehen eingedrungen, du bist in Wien, was was kreist so primär um dich herum derzeit.
Was kreist du mich äh so Netzpolitik, Netzkultur? Habe ich dich Podcasts kennengelernt? Und,
wir haben ja ein cooles in Wien, das politisch gesehen gab's da nie was. Ich hab mir immer gedacht das sind wichtige Themen aber damit war ich lange allein,
und im letzten Jahr ist aber was passiert, da hat sich irgendwie die Situation verdichtet und es sind immer mehr Aktionen passiert und auf einmal gibt's da Leute, die wirklich was bewegen.
Hm. Ähm was man zu dir noch sagen kann, ist, du machst auch selber noch Podcast, zwei an der Zahl.
Ja, ich mache äh das habe ich so mit meinem Studium angefangen
und äh dann bin ich noch bei Signal Hackers Basis. Das ist so ein Podcast Kollektiv in der Hackers Basis Punkt ORG Bewegung dran
und sonst äh so wirklich institutionell verhaftet, bin ich nur beim Ackervorrat und zwischen den anderen Organisationen bin ich so, dass frei radikal, was hin und her schwimmt und
ja, der Klima ist zwischen den anderen Gruppen.
Gut, dann werden wir uns nachher nochmal ein bisschen genauer zu Gemüte führen, was da im Einzelnen so läuft. Jetzt sollten wir uns vielleicht nochmal kurz um die äh Fehler der vergangenen Woche kümmern.
Also vergangene Woche war alles falsch, was ich erzählt habe zu dem äh Facebook-Urteil. Und zwar war es nicht das Berliner Landesgericht,
Sondern ein Berliner Landesgericht, nämlich das Berliner Landgericht.
Man muss ja genau sein, ne?
Ja, um das vielleicht kurz aufzuklären. Landesgericht ist alles bis Oberlandesgericht, wenn ich das jetzt richtig verstehe. Und Landgericht.
Ich glaube Landesgerichte schließt auch.
Genau. Genau.
Amtsgerichte ein. Genau. Sind halt alle die, die nicht Bundesgerichte sind, sind halt Landesgerichte und da gibt's dann halt unter anderem auch ein Landgericht.
Genau. Und dieses Landgericht ist in der Hierarchie der Gerichte zwischen Amts und Oberland des Gerichts.
Ja ja, ist nicht so, dass es jetzt einfach zu verstehen wäre, aber irgendwie so ist es.
Einfach so nur insofern, wir haben das ja jetzt erklärt äh in Zukunft sind da also Irrtümer ausgeschlossen.
Genau, wir wollen halt die körperlichen Schmerzen für diejenigen reduzieren, die es gerne ganz genau nehmen. Wir nehmen's ja eigentlich auch immer sehr gerne genauer und von daher haben wir das jetzt auch mal klargestellt.
Stell dir mal vor, du bist auf einmal vorm falschen Gericht.
Ansonsten war aber alles richtig, was wir gesagt haben.
Glaube ich. Das ist gut. Also sonst hat sich keiner beklagt.
Das gut, dann können wir ja, sonst hat sich keiner beklagt. Also zumindest konnte er uns bisher noch nichts anderes nachgewiesen werden. Ja, das bringt uns dann zum ersten Thema. Mehr Transparenz ist gefragt.
Ja ähm es geht mal wieder um und zwar hat ja die Bundesregierung äh verlautbaren lassen, dass sie an all diesen Verhandlungsrunden, die stattgefunden haben zum Thema äh teilgenommen hat,
Und dann hat Matthias Schindler
der grade äh sich zum zum großen Freund des Portals fragt den Staat äh mausert, fragt den Staat, wir erinnern uns, hatten wir sogar ähm einmal im genauer vorgestellt im Rahmen des äh
achtundzwanzig C drei. Die Plattform, bei der man Informationsfreiheitsgesetzanfragen stellen kann. Und Matthias Schindler hat dann ähm eine
Anfrage gestellt
und wollte ganz gerne wissen, wer denn so als Vertreter der Bundesregierung an den Verhandlungen teilgenommen hat, hat da irgendwie elf Teilfragen gestellt, zu jeder einzelnen Verhandlungsrunde in Japan, in und wo die überall stattgefunden haben. Und in Frage elf verlangte er dann auch noch.
Ähm alle,
jeweiligen Dokumente dazu und dann kamen so die Standardantwort, äh es wird ein Arbeitsaufwand entstehen, der den Rahmen einer einfachen Auskunft übersteigt, äh wofür dann fünfhundert Euro erhoben werden. Und diese,
das aber so diese normale Abschreckungsmaßnahme, die man so bekommt, wenn man eine Informationsfreiheitsgesetzanfrage stellt. Also hat er dann einfach gesagt, alles klar, dann sparen wir uns Frage elf, dass ich alle Dokumente dazu haben möchte.
Wobei fünfhundert Euro wählen und auch nicht das Problem gewesen, oder?
Ja ähm also das war dann erstmal noch so seine kurze Antwort, das mit den fünfhundert Euro ist inzwischen sowieso kein Problem mehr. Das kommt dann am Ende der,
Ähm dann hat er gesagt, ja okay, dann streichen wir mal Frage elf und dann äh kam er eine erneute Antwort.
Und dann wurde gesagt, ja äh wir wir haben ihre, ihrem Antrag äh stattgegeben, aber wir nennen ihnen nur die Ressorts und keine Personennamen.
Und dabei berufen wir uns auf Paragraph Paragraph drei Nummer zwei Informationsfreiheitsgesetz, Gefährdung der öffentlichen Sicherheit.
Ähm
und man zitiert das Bekanntwerden der Informationen zu den Personen, die für die Bundesregierung bei den Verhandlungsrunden zu Akte Anwesend waren, kann die öffentliche Sicherheit, zu der auch die Rechtsgüter der betroffenen Mitarbeiter gehören, gefährden.
Insbesondere könnten die Namen der Mitarbeiter, die gemäß einem dem Antrag des Antragstellers angefügten Hinweis auf einer Webseite veröffentlicht werden,
von Dritten dazu verwendet worden in werden in unangemessener Form gegen sie vorzugehen.
Einzelnen Internetforen, Blogs und im Netz eingestellten Videos sowie dazugehörigen Kommentaren wird zum Teil eine vom sachlichen Regelungsgehalt der Bestimmung des Abkommens losgelöste, emotionale Diskussion geführt
der auch eher verletzende Äußerungen und Drogen mit Gewalt gegen an acta beteiligte Personen ausgesprochen werden,
erscheint da im Falle der Herausgabe der Daten, der bei den Verhandlungsrunden, anwesenden Personen hinreichend möglich, dass Personen,
dass diese Person persönlich bedrängt oder sonst gegen sie unangemessen vorgegangen wird. Ja.
Die öffentliche Sicherheit ist also jetzt die Sicherheit dieser Behördenmitarbeiter sozusagen.
Ist also besser, wenn keiner weiß, wer irgendwo wann, unter welchen Bedingungen Akte ausgehandelt hat.
Weil er könnte ja unter Umständen vielleicht irgendwo Eis auf die Mütze kriegen, weil irgendwo im Internet eine Seite steht.
Er könnte im Internet kritisiert werden. Es könnte theoretisch jemand ihn kritisieren, ja. Also ich meine jetzt, dass dass da jemand verletzt wird oder so, das,
wirklich einfach nur an den Haaren herbeigezogen, ja, aber es wird äh also man möchte, man möchte das nicht machen. Jetzt ähm natürlich kann dagegen Widerspruch eingelegt werden,
Matthias hat dann sich an den Bundesbeauftragten für Daten.
Also öffentliche das muss man sich echt mal auf der Zunge zergehen lassen, wenn ich das richtig also so öffentlich gewählte Staatsvertreter beziehungsweise die von ihnen bestimmten Personen.
Eher die von ihnen bestimmten Personen, ja.
Ja, genau, so rum.
Führen ein ähm machen ein internationales Handelsabkommen oder führen Verhandlungen zu einem internationalen Handelsabkommen.
Und auf die Frage hin, wer denn das denn nun genau gewesen wäre, sagt man, dass das kann man ja nicht sagen, weil.
Weil ihr alle dagegen sind.
Weil das ja so Scheiße ist, dass das und so und da so so ein Schmu ausgehandelt werden würde, dass er ähm dafür ja eins auf die Mütze kriegen könnte, in welcher Form auch immer. So.
Ist das geil. Da muss man erstmal drauf kommen. Das ist schon wirklich elegant.
Ja. Ich find's auch, also ich meine, mal ganz.
Auch künftig verschweigen, wer Bundeskanzler ist, so so.
Kann man nicht sagen. Überleg mal, was der für fein hat.
Ja also was für Dinge da ausgekugelt werden auf dem Level, ja, also da kann man ja jetzt nicht so öffentlich drüber sprechen.
Ist wohl schon zurückgetreten, das können wir nicht sagen.
Ach ja. Was für ein schöner Montag übrigens.
Jetzt ist natürlich das das Interessante ist, ähm wenn ich jetzt mal ehrlich sein soll, also mein persönlich, ich finde jetzt persönlich nicht so enorm daran interessiert, wie die Personen tatsächlich heißen,
totaler PR-Fail, irgendwie dann noch so eine IFG-Anfrage zu. Ich meine, das warum sitzt da keiner und sagt, hey Freunde, hier so, ne, wir haben wegen Akteur, die hauptsächlich deshalb Ärger, weil wir das intransparent aushandeln und äh niemanden gefragt haben, ähm,
So, wenn jetzt deine Informationsfreiheitsgesetzanfrage kommt, so, was machen wir als Erstes? Ablehnen. Ja, so,
statt zu sagen, okay, komm hier, alles kein Problem und wir nehmen euch mal ein bisschen den Wind ausm Segeln, ja. Okay, also Matthias, dann äh hat dann den,
Hat sich dann in den Bundesbeauftragten für Datenschutz und Informationsfreiheit äh gewendet und um Vermittlung gebeten
und sagte, ja wenn die mir die beteiligten Ressourcen nennen, die Namen der Ressortleiter sind ohnehin öffentlich, das kann man sich ohnehin denken. Ähm
Naja und dann sagte äh digitale Gesellschaft, der Verein.
Ja, wir wollen das äh unterstützen und haben äh dann einen Spendenaufruf getätigt und haben gesagt, hier wenn fünfhundert Euro zusammenkommen, dann äh,
geben wir das Geld dafür aus, auch an diese Dokumente zu kommen und wenn äh tausend Euro zusammenkommen, dann äh unterstützen wir die Klage gegen den also die Klage gegen die Ablehnung und kämpfen das Ding einfach mal jetzt,
ähm juristisch durch. Ähm wenn da bei dieser Spendenaktion dann Geld überschüssig wird und zu viel gespendet wird
dann äh wird das in weitere Informationsfreiheitsgesetzanfragen an die Ministerien Auswärtiges Amt äh Justiz, Wirtschaft, Kanzleramt gesteckt, um irgendwie an alle Akte Unterlagen zu kommen. Also ähm,
ähm,
Finde ich eine eine ganz, ganz interessante Sache, auch wenn ich, wie gesagt, den den tatsächlichen Punkt eigentlich nur so, es ist halt so ein wirkliches, so ein wirklicher PR-Fale, ja.
Dass da ähm diese berühmten Verhandlungsdokumente Schuld dran sind, die man ja nicht einsehen darf, weil äh mich würd's nicht wundern, wenn da unter anderem auch drinsteht, dass die Verhandler im Persona nicht genannt werden dürfen von den Regierungen.
Das wäre natürlich jetzt nochmal spannend ähm.
Ich weiß nicht, ob irgendwo aus irgendeinem Land die Personen, die da wirklich am Tisch saßen, bekannt sind.
Ja ich das mag gut sein, dass das nicht so ist. Ich würde halt auch sagen, vielleicht ist es gar nicht so unbedingt.
Vielleicht ist es nicht so wichtig, welche Personen das waren, sondern eher die Inhalte. Es könnte natürlich, ist natürlich auch die Frage, wenn man sagt, man will alle Dokumente dazu haben, dann müsst ihr eigentlich über diese IFG-Anfrage eben genau auch diese,
letztendlich müsste man die soweit durchkämpfen, dass man genau diese Verhandlungsdokumente bekommt, die ja eben nicht öffentlich sein sollen. Ich denke, da sitzt äh natürlich auch der der wirkliche Kern dieser Anfrage auf die,
den da damit abgezielt wird. Ähm.
Diese Argumentation über die Person und dass das Internet jetzt irgendwie böse ist, ist natürlich ähm ist natürlich,
ist einfach nur lächerlich, ne? Also, ich meine, das das ist wirklich der ähm hier Thomas Stadler,
Rechtsanwalt Internet als Gefahr für die öffentliche Sicherheit dargestellt wird
haben wir es mit einer Begründungstechnik zu tun, die totalitäre Züge trägt und die der Regierung eines demokratischen Staates unwürdig ist, wird er sehr gerne sehr pathetisch mal, aber.
Ja
Der hat ja im Prinzip recht, ja? Also wenn du wenn du sagst, hier wir machen hier einen auf äh Demokratie und äh notwendig irgendwie Informationen. Das Volk muss irgendwie informiert sein, um,
die Abläufe irgendwie zu zu kennen und bewerten zu können äh und dann zu sagen, nee, ähm wir wir können diese Person nicht der öffentlichen Meinung preisgeben,
sehr komische Begründungstaktik. Auf jeden Fall, wie gesagt, spenden sind möglich, digitale Gesellschaft e. V. Nimmt hier da entgegen, kommen äh Formular habe ich verlinkt und ähm wie gesagt.
Selbst wenn man, selbst wenn so viel Geld gespendet wird, dass alle äh alle juristischen Auseinandersetzungen irgendwie ausgefochten werden,
Dann noch etwas überbliebe, dann würde es weiter in die Informationsarbeit gehen. Acta äh investiert werden. Das heißt, da hat man also eine sehr klare ähm,
Kampagne dort teambezogene Spender in digitale Gesellschaft. Was ja was eigentlich nicht nicht üblicherweise der Fall ist bei Betty gegessen,
äh wirklich konkret Kampagnen bezogen gespendet wird. In dem Fall,
wollte ich da mal drauf aufmerksam machen. Ansonsten noch kurz zu Acta äh die Petition zum Aussetzen der Ratifizierung,
Die hat nämlich jetzt die Anhörung gewonnen. Das ist ja, man gewinnt ja quasi die Anhörung, wenn man in einem,
gewissen Zeitraum ab Beginn der des der Einstellung des Staates der Petition quasi äh über fünfzigtausend kommt,
Frist waren, glaube ich, im letzten Jahr noch drei Wochen, jetzt sind's irgendwie vier.
Und äh diese Hürde hat diese Petition gerissen. Sie kann noch bis zum zweiundzwanzigsten mitgezeichnet werden, steht jetzt glaube ich grade knapp vor den vor der Sechzigtausend,
Da haben wir also eine schöne äh Petition. Üblicherweise bis,
Also dann gibt's ja quasi dann kommt der Petent ja vor den Petitionsausschuss und hat da seine Anhörung üblicherweise dauert das noch sehr lange bis da irgendwann mal irgendwie ein Termin gefunden wird. Aber äh immerhin.
Ähm erfolgreiche Sache, die da, glaube ich, der Vater eines fünfzehnjährigen Jungen aus Gefälligkeit für ihn gestartet hat, wenn ich das richtig.
Verlinkt, kann man auch noch mitzeichnen.
Kann man auch mitzeichnen, wenn man äh nicht Deutscher ist, auch äh EU-Staatsangehörige können Petitionen auf Bundestags DE mitzeichnen. So als kleine.
Echt, echt es war mir wirklich nicht bekannt.
Doch, doch. Ah, gibt's doch eigene Felder dafür, also das ist ganz legitim, da kann man auch auswählen, dass man aus Österreich oder sonst wo kommt. Ich glaube, ich weiß nicht, ob das extra gezählt wird, aber auf jeden Fall ist es möglich in dem Formular.
Interessant, wusste ich auch noch nicht.
Mit dem Thema? Ja, ne? Ja, dann äh gab es eine Dialog beim Bundes äh Wirtschaftsministerium zum Thema.
True Strikes. Tue Strikes ist ja wirklich eins der merkwürdigsten Basswörter irgendwie, das sollte man, haben wir das schon mal klargestellt? Ich weiß nicht, das.
Ja, also wir haben.
Man vielleicht auch schon noch mal machen, ne?
Es kommt ja von den von der Regelung in, die in Frankreich mit dem Gesetz zumindest formell ja in Kraft getreten ist, ähm wo.
Ein ein eine Infrastruktur eingerichtet wird, dass das automatisch überwacht wird, wer ähm über seinen Internetzugang das äh Urheberrecht verletzt. Und ähm,
Wenn das festgestellt wird, dann gibt's ein gibt's einen blauen Brief nach Hause, wo dann drin steht hier, du, du, du, hast du nicht ist nicht richtig gemacht mit dem Internet, musst was anderes machen mit dem Internet, was anderes runterladen und dann nach der dritten Verwarnung,
Beim dritten Mal erwischen soll dann eine Sanktion stattfinden. Nämlich, dass der Internetanschluss äh.
Gesperrt wird oder man überhaupt kein Zugang mehr bekommen darf.
Für eine gewisse Zeit oder äh so. Äh in den.
Genau, also dreimal äh kriegst du's um die Ohren gehauen und dann.
Wird in den USA, in etwas anderer Form,
Debattiert und da haben sie gesagt, okay, wir äh wir schalten euch den Internetanschluss nicht ab, weil dann würden den Provider, der auch im Zweifel zwei Kohle entgehen. Sie können ja nicht,
auf die auf die auf das Bezahlen ihres Vertrages äh bestehen, wenn sie gleichzeitig die den Internetanschluss abschneiden,
so dass die in USA eher sowas diskutiert wird wie Bandbreitendrosselung, also du hast halt 'n weiß ich nicht 'n VDSL-Vertrag, aber wenn du das dritte Mal erwischt wirst, wie du irgendwie urheberrechtlich relevantes Material runterlässt,
wird er halt auf Mode um Geschwindigkeit gedrosselt. Das heißt, du kannst halt die können dir weiterhin Kohle abnehmen, ja? Und müssen dir weniger Dienstleistungen. Also das, das bedeutet,
ja, also die ultimativ die Gefahr, dass mein Internetanschluss äh,
abgeschaltet oder irgendwie äh zum Schlechten manipuliert wird,
Ähm und gleichzeitig damit einhergehend, also eine ins eine Infrastruktur, die genau das überwacht und diese diese Sperrung dann ermöglichen soll. In Frankreich ist das dann dieses äh,
oder was, das hat äh Jeremy Zimmermann im Podcast mit Markus Beckedal äh bei Netzpolitik org nochmal genauer erklärt. Das soll jetzt auch gar nicht unser Thema sein, nämlich in Deutschland wird jetzt two Strikes.
Diskutiert. So und wer jetzt verstanden hat, was bedeutet, würde sagen, Tue Strikes heißt, ich muss nicht dreimal den Fehler machen, sondern zweimal reicht. Und ich bin raus,
Das ist aber falsch. Das ist falsch. Ähm richtig ist ähm.
Heißt, weniger Sanktionen.
Heißt keine Sanktion, ich kriege nur einen Brief.
Also wer denkt sich sowas aus?
So und jetzt und dieser Brief soll.
Ähm nach also man kann sich natürlich vorstellen, wer diese Idee hatte. Das sind die ähm die Rechteverwerter, die äh sagen, ja, da müssen wir irgendwie mal was machen,
Und was sie also mit ganz gerne haben wollen, ist, dass diese Verwarnung direkt vom Provider ähm versendet wird,
und dass die Verantwortung zu den Providern geschoben wird, auch diese Überwachung zu veranstalten. Äh momentan ist es ja so, dass wenn ich jetzt, sagen wir mal, ich lade jetzt, warte mal, ich ich lade einen Torwart runter, irgendein neues Album,
Was vielleicht vor einer Woche rausgekommen ist, dann lade ich äh lade ich illegal als so ein so ein Album herunter, die die,
Der Weg, wie ich dabei erwischt werde, ist, dass ähm eine private äh,
Ermittlungsorganisation der der Rechte Verwalter genau in diesem Tourent mit drin hängt und quasi meint die Beteiligung meiner IP-Adresse feststellt,
dann ähm Feststellung macht, wem gehörte diese IP-Adresse zu dieser Uhrzeit? Und dann kriege ich meine meine Abmahnung oder oder mein mein strafbewerte Unterlassungserklärung oder was auch immer sie von mir verlangen, irgendwas wo wo ich am Ende Geld bezahlen muss,
Im Moment müssen quasi die Rechteinhaber selber ermitteln auf auf eigene Faust in diesen in diesen dann rein.
Und dann beim Provider äh nach der Gesetzesreform von zweitausendacht ähm so eine ähm,
So eine Anfrage dann stellen so. Und das denen natürlich viel zu aufwendig und die wollen jetzt natürlich viel lieber, dass die dass die Providers von vorneherein machen wollen.
Von vorneherein machen und ihnen die Arbeit abnehmen, ja?
Ähm das heißt, da soll so diese Rechtsverfolgung so ein bisschen privatisiert werden. Der Provider ist selber dafür verantwortlich haftet vielleicht im Idealfall äh der Vorstellung noch direkt dafür. Und der Provider
verliert quasi seine die Inhaltsnetralität seines seines Angebotes und äh wird dazu verpflichtet.
Gegen seine eigenen Nutzer da vorzugehen.
Eine ganz großartige Idee.
Genau, wird diskutiert seit Ende zweitausendachtzehn ungefähr, seitdem lädt nämlich das Bundeswirtschaftsministerium regelmäßig zum Wirtschaftsdialog, zur Bekämpfung von Urheberrechtsverletzungen ein. Und da kommen dann eben unsere äh Rechte,
Anbieter äh Rechteverwerter,
Wie jetzt äh der Bundesverband der Musikindustrie zum Beispiel und ähm so Gruppen wie Eco, der ähm.
Verband in Deutschland.
Verband, aber eigentlich noch sind nicht alles nur Provider, sondern auch äh andere Internetanbieter. Ähm,
Kommt dann dahin und dann unterhalten sie sich und,
Ähm wer nicht eingeladen war, war irgendjemand von der Zivilgesellschaft. Also es war weder irgendwie AK Zensur, AK Vorrat, äh digitale Gesellschaft für Boots, CCC, irgendjemand war da gefragt. Da gab's dann einen großen,
Protest natürlich von allen Seiten,
und das also quasi für Sanktionen der Nutzer da irgendwie diskutiert werden soll und kein einziger Nutzer da an an Bord ist. Aber in diesem Fall haben dann die Provider,
relativ starke
relativ klare Kante gezeigt und zwar sagt Verfahren sind in Deutschland datenschutzrechtlich, verfassungsrechtlich, zweifelsfrei unzulässig, machen wir nicht mit, äh Rechteinhaber können ja bereits selbst
selbst äh ständig Warnhinweise versenden. Sehen wir nicht ein, warum das irgendwie auf die Provider gehen soll,
Sprecher, wir lehnen das Modell ab, da dies eine Privatisierung der Rechtsverfolgung Urheberrechts sowie eine Aufweichung der neutralen Rolle der Provider, wie sie in der E-Commerce-Richtlinie und im Telemediengesetz niedergelegt ist, zur Folge hätte.
Schön, diese Gespräche sind also gescheit.
Scheitert, ja.
Und da kann man mal sehen, dass dieser Eco äh mit seinen vierzig Mitarbeitern große Lobby-Organisationen der Provider äh auch mal,
und zwar nicht zum ersten Mal da ziemlich gute Arbeit im Rahmen des des schonens von Grundrechten.
Vor allem auch,
extrem erfreuliches, selbstbewusstes Auftreten. Also, äh, wenn ich mich so erinnere, grade so an Interessenvertreter, äh, aus der Wirtschaft, wenn die mal irgendwas nicht passt in der Hinsicht und dann auch schnell mal wieder so diese Kinderpornokeule oder was auch immer gerade so äh das Argument des Tages war
gezogen wird,
Ist dann so häufig so, ja, das ist ja ein ganz netter Vorschlag und da muss man ja sicherlich mal drüber reden und da könnten wir uns aber auch noch vorstellen, dass da ein paar Änderungen angemessen wären et cetera ja, obwohl sie eigentlich alle keinen Bock drauf haben
es wird einfach nur gesagt so, habt ihr schon mal das Grundgesetz geguckt und so? Äh wir gehen jetzt mal zu den Schnittchen, nächstes Thema.
Und das finde ich äh das finde ich schon ganz bemerkenswert so, das äh da hat sich schon der Stil schon so ein bisschen geändert.
Weil man natürlich auch sagen muss, wenn man jetzt wirklich den Providern diese, diese Pflicht aufs Auge drückt, dass sie den, das kostet ein Schweinegeld.
Vor allem auch für ihre Reputation katastrophal, ne? Ich meine wer ich meine null Komma nix hältst du so die Blacklist äh im Internet, hier sind deine Zensurprovider des Tages, äh
hier ist das Formular zum schnellen Wechseln, hier ist euer sonder Kündigungsrecht, weil sich der Vertrag geändert hat. Go for it, ne? Und da haben die natürlich auch alle einen Riesenschiss davor.
So ist es. Wie gesagt, diese Gespräche, schön, diese Gespräche waren jetzt äh zielten auf eine freiwillige Lösung. Ähm.
Es ging da wirklich darum, dass das Bundeswirtschaftsministerium setzt euch doch mal an einen Tisch und vielleicht werdet ihr euch einig, ähm das heißt, die Situation ist jetzt eigentlich das Wirtschaftsministerium, will diese,
Justizministerium will sie nicht,
Das heißt, dass da irgendwie eine gesetzliche Grundlage jetzt entsteht, ist zumindest in der jetzigen äh Regierungskonstellation eher unwahrscheinlich.
Und was, sage ich mal, so ein bisschen als ähm,
Kompromiss oder das, worüber man mal nachdenken könnte aus diesen Gesprächen äh hervorgegangen ist, dass man sagt, okay, wir könnten uns überlegen, irgendwie eine größere Aufklärungskampagne zu machen oder wir streben an,
E-Bike
Werbeanbieter, die Finanzierung von Piraterieseiten zu kappen, das ja auch immer seit einiger Zeit so eine Idee, die da eine Rolle spielt, was weiß ich, ne. Es gibt irgendwie bei diesen Piraterie-Seiten
Unmengen an Werbefinanzierung. Dadurch funktionieren die, ähm, dass man versucht, da vielleicht Allianzen zu schmieden, um zu sagen, okay, wir äh,
schalten keine Werbung mehr auf mega Upload oder oder Pirate oder was auch immer, um den so die Grundlage zu entziehen,
Und aber auch, dass man sich drüber nach, dass man sich irgendwie verbesserte Ermittlungszusammenarbeit und internationale Rechtsdurchsetzung wünscht. Okay, da sind wir dann auch nicht mehr so weit weg von Arkta, ne? Aber das waren,
Wie gesagt, ähm eine gesetzliche Regelung in der jetzigen Konstellation dank äh Justizministerium, Ministerin, Leuthäuser Schnarrenberger,
eher unwahrscheinlich.
Akte sind in diesem Eco-Branchen-Verband aller Provider vertreten.
Da sind sowas von viele drin, dass viele Sachen kenne ich dann auch gar nicht. Warte, ich habe die mit.
Also das heißt Verband der deutschen Internetwirtschaft EV, also von daher geht es eben deutlich weiter als Provider. Das ist aber, glaube ich, ursprünglich mal wirklich aus dem Provider Umfeld entstanden. Ja. Oder täusche ich mich?
Das ist das kommt so aus diesem Umfeld, wenn du da jetzt schaust hier die Mitgliederliste, da ist Telekom Austria zum Beispiel auch drin, ja ähm dann.
Okay, sind viele, ja.
Da sind also wirklich sehr viele drin und die haben sich da echt eine eine ordentliche,
eine ordentliche ähm Lobby-Organisation aufgebaut mit dem Eco, ne. Wie gesagt, der hat vierzig Mitarbeiter. Das ist äh das sind richtig fettes Ding. Gut, da sind jetzt, auf weiß ich nicht, wie viele hundert äh Mitglieder drin.
Unternehmen. Na, es erinnert mich nämlich ein bisschen an die aktuelle Diskussion, die wir hatten in Österreich, über diese Privatisierung von Rechtsdurchsetzung
und Provider müssen Polizei spielen, entscheiden, was legal und illegal ist und äh im Grunde in die Netzzentraität eingreifen.
Und da gibt's halt die die Ispa, Internetservice, Provider Austria und die hat sich da auch ganz stark ausgesprochen dagegen. Das ist ein Verband von allen Providern, bis auf die zwei größten.
Und die haben natürlich andere Meinungen, also da ist auch Ispa, wenn du, wenn man die zur Netzzentraität fragt, hat man auch
eher positive Antworten, die trauen sich auch mal ein bissel auf die Kacke zu hauen, aber ja,
halt die die zwei größten fehlen und die kaufen natürlich auch gerne mal wieder die Kleinen. Also.
Sind die Deutsche Telekom beim Ikone.
Die finde ich jetzt gerade nicht in dieser Mitgliederliste, die wirklich, wie gesagt, sehr lang ist.
Ja, der Hintergrund ist es ja oft, dass die großen Firmen allein schon so viel Gewicht haben, dass sie sich nicht in so ein Gremium oder einen Verband reinsetzen.
Na ja, eben da, lassen die sich gar nicht die Butter vom Brot nehmen, also Deutsche Telekom ist hier nicht dabei.
Telekom ist nicht dabei, nee. Aber, wie gesagt, eins und eins, SAP, also da da ist wirklich riesige Liste hier, kann man sich mal anschauen. Eco ist auf jeden Fall wirklich, sage ich mal, von diesen.
Von diesen Organisationen äh immer immer eine gute, also von Eco kommen selten irgendwelche ähm blöden Stellungnahmen. Da kann man wirklich sagen, dass man da jetzt,
Als ähm jemand, der möglichst wenig Einschränkungen fordert und möglichst äh,
neutral, möglichst sich einen neutrale Netzvermittlung wünscht, kann man mit den Positionen des Eco äh in der Regel sehr gut übereinstimmen und sich sehr über die Arbeit freuen, die die da leisten.
Ganz im Gegensatz zu jetzt anderen wie Bitcom, ne?
Haben wir noch Anmerkungen zum Thema. Das Ding ist, glaube ich, erstmal gegessen, oder?
Ja, wie gesagt, also äh gegessen, so lange sich an der Konstellation Wirtschaftsministerium, Justizministerium erstmal nichts ändert, wird's da keine äh gesetzliche Initiative geben.
Hm. So, dann gab es einen Fluggastdatenabkommen zwischen wem?
Das soll es erst geben und zwar möchte die
EU das gerne mit den äh USA abschließen, dass sämtliche Fluggastdaten irgendwie an die äh USA gesendet werden und dort für fünfzehn Jahre gespeichert.
Das beinhaltet dann irgendwie, also im Prinzip alle Daten, die irgendwie anfallen, wenn man so ein äh Flug angeht.
Ähm also was weiß ich, Kreditkarte, was man gerne isst, äh man kann ja irgendwie sein Kreuz bei Vegetarisch machen. Also alles was, was irgendwie die Airline und so weiter irgendwie über einen bekommen, wenn man da fliegt.
Und die sollen äh laut momentan Stand des Abkommens soll die, das Department vor homeland security, die dann diese Daten einfach per Impulsverfahren sich aus äh,
aus Europa holen können und dann irgendwie nutzen zum Kampf gegen Terror und illegale Immigration. Eines der größten Probleme, die USA haben, ist ja illegale Immigration aus Europa, weil alle so gerne,
dahin wollen.
Flüchten geradezu dahinten, ne? Endlich Freiheit.
Ähm und das äh und Homeland Security kann die dann auch äh in den USA an alle äh Behörden, die ihm so einfallen, weitergeben,
Da gibt's äh seit längerer Zeit einen Kampf gegen, da eben die Anforderungen des EU-Parlaments, die da schon vor einigen Jahren,
definiert wurden, nicht erfüllt werden, die können das also man kann offensichtlich mit diesen Daten Profile bilden
Sie sollten nur zur Terrorabwehr zum Einsatz kommen, aber im Moment nach aktuellem Stand kann die USA, die eigentlich im Prinzip für alles verwenden
Es gibt dann vor allem für keine Rechtssicherheit, weil die da ein Abkommen mit homeland security machen wollen,
und nicht einen wirklichen internationalen Vertrag, den man einklagen kann. Das äh heißt, wenn ich jetzt aus irgendwelchen Gründen auf so einer äh Blacklist lande.
Ein Abkommen mit einer Behörde sozusagen.
Also die die eine, es gibt es soll quasi kein internationaler Vertrag zwischen USA und den Ländern entstehen, nachdem ich als Betroffener, also der, der, der Punkt ist, ich, ich, Linus Neumann fliege irgendwie zu oft nah äh in Iran.
So dass äh die USA dann irgendwie feststellen, nee, den den Neumann, den wollen wir bei uns nicht, der ist immer im Iran. So und dann bin ich auf so einer No-Fleitlist. Ja und dann wird halt einfach,
kann ich kann ich dann nicht, geht nicht. Und äh quasi, dass wenn ich auf so einer Liste lande, hätte ich nach dem aktuellen Stand des,
abkommst, wenn es so unterzeichnet wird, ähm keine Möglichkeit, mich da irgendwie wieder runterzuklagen. Weil das ja einfach äh die Daten haben, das die haben einfach einfach die Daten treffen da ihre Entscheidung und es gibt da keine, keine ernstzunehmende Rechtssicherheit.
Da gibt's eben die Kampagne No P NRTs dot org ähm,
die sich dagegen engagierte ja noch sehr viel mehr Informationen zu hat. Auch hier gibt's eine Kampagne von digitale Gesellschaft EV,
die sich da in dem Fall daran wendet, dass man seine äh M,
die die MEP Members of European Parlament anschreibt und denen sagt, hier lass mal sein, wollen wir nicht. Ähm insgesamt gab's dann auch noch eine eine Studie, die also sagte, das ist,
gesamte, das gesamte Abkommen hat eigentlich nur Nachteile für äh,
für den EU-Bürger, ja? Es werden einfach deine Daten da rausgeblasen, an die USA und für fünfzehn Jahre da behalten, die können die Pullen, sie müssen die noch nicht mal anfragen, ja. Sie haben sie haben im Prinzip quasi dann Ruth auf die Datenbank, ja. Ähm.
Und das scheint also im Moment ein sehr, sehr unausgewogenes.
Aber es gibt auch ähm es gibt doch bereits ein Abkommen zwischen Europa und den USA über die Fluggastdaten. Inwiefern ist jetzt diese Initiative,
Oder täusche ich mich? Ist das irgendwo im letzten Moment gescheitert? Meines Wissens gibt es eine Datenübermittlung. In dem Moment, wo jemand in die USA fliegt, können die USA ja auf diese Daten zugreifen? Oder habe ich da was falsch mitbekommen und wieder.
Wenn du in USA liegst natürlich jetzt geht's ja wenn ich das hier jetzt richtig verstehe geht's ja einfach mal um alles.
Also egal, wohin ich fliege, sozusagen, wir hätten gerne einfach mal alles. Sagt uns einfach mal, was ihr weißt, damit unsere unsere Geheimdienste werden zu teuer, äh, äh, es wäre doch viel einfacher, wenn die Länder, äh, sich sozusagen selbst ausspionieren würden, dann,
Nicht so viel Geld investieren, ist das irgendwie so eine Nummer? Ist wirklich unglaublich.
Also ich will jetzt hier grade nichts Falsches sein, deswegen schaue ich noch mal irgendwie genau drauf, aber ähm.
In die Richtung geht's, sagst du.
Ja. Ich schaue jetzt gerade noch ganz kurz. Ich weil ich bin ganz ehrlich, dass ich bei diesem Thema nicht so drinstecke und eigentlich nur mal schnell darauf verweisen wollte, dass es das alles gibt.
Ja, okay, gut. Dann haben wir darauf verwiesen.
Also vielleicht.
Ähm also die, also es gibt auf jeden Fall bei diesem diesen Abkommen geht's ja drum, dass das ausgeweitet wird und ähm dass im Grunde jede Flugbewegung auch die hier, also innerhalb von Europa, dass die damit auch übermittelt werden,
Gesagt hat, eben auch alle Datenfelder, die ich da angebe bei meiner Airline,
und äh die Geschichte ist halt, dass das Abkommen ist eine Ausweitung und wirklich aufmerksam darauf gemacht hat, Alexander Sander, der steckt hinter No P N R. Und der sitzt in Brüssel und macht da Netzpolitik,
und äh es ist halt schon durch.
Das alleine oder macht er das für irgendeine andere Organisation?
Der macht das der ist irgendwie Angestellter von 'nem österreichischen, unabhängigen MIP, also Europaparlamentsabgeordneten, Martin Ehrenhauser,
und äh der hat sich irgendwie so auf die Netzpolitik gestützt dieser Ehrenhase und beschäftigt halt eben den Zander,
Dadurch kann der da in Brüsseler arbeiten und ist immer bei den ganzen Ausschüssen dabei und gibt halt Updates und,
versucht irgendwie mit den Leuten zu reden, aber jetzt ist es halt an einem Punkt, wo es im Parlament auch noch abgesegnet werden muss, durch den Rat ist es schon durch,
und um eben auf das Parlament einzuwirken, weil's dort halt wirklich ein freies Mandat gibt, versucht er jetzt sozusagen nochmal äh über die einzelnen Länder mit dieser PNR-Webseite, die Leute zuzubringen, ihre eigenen Abgeordneten anzuschreiben,
was diese Webseite tut. Ich glaube, PNR Punkt digitale Gesellschaft DE oder PNR Punkt Vibe AT. Äh wir haben das auch,
Da siehst du alle deine Abgeordneten, die sind halt eingeteilt in sind für PNR, sind gegen PNR oder sind so Wackelkandidaten.
Und äh die Idee ist eben, dass man hier mal Argumente bekommt, was man den Leuten sagen könnte und dann Kontaktinformationen, die einzelnen ähm Parlamentarier anzuschreiben und zu versuchen, zu überzeugen, dass die da dagegen sind,
Und wenn man Antworten bekommt, können wir die auch in dieser Homepage eintragen. Sprich, das soll so irgendwie mal darstellen, wie ist der Ist-Zustand,
und auch aktiv darauf hinarbeiten, dass die Leute sozusagen ihre eigenen MEPs anschreiben und so wird das bei Akta ja auch schon gemacht haben. Da gab's auch dasselbe Tool. Es ist irgendwie eine dänische Software, die ja auch schon damals eingesetzt hat,
und äh das ist irgendwie so ein Trend, der sich durchsetzt, dass man äh ganz einfach darstellt, wie sind für dieses Thema gerade die Mehrheitsverhältnisse und wie können Bürger ihre eigenen Abgeordneten dazu bringen, da ein bissel mehr in die Richtung zu gehen.
Und äh das ist so, weiß nicht, eine neue Form von Gras Roots Lobby und das macht's halt einfacher, als diese ganzen Wickelisten, die wir da vorher mal hatten, mit such dir deinen Abgeordneten und,
Wird halt einfacher.
Natürlich auch gefährdet natürlich die öffentliche Sicherheit, ne? Weil da die Abgeordneten auf einmal im Internet stehen mit ihrer Meinung. Oh ja.
Oh ja. Da könnte man sie ja nicht mehr wählen, weil sie irgendwas Blödes.
Ich werde nachher äh wird da die öffentliche Sicherheit gefährdet.
Ja, ich würde sagen, bei diesem Fluggast-Daten-Abkommen wird aber auch die öffentliche Sicherheit gefährdet, wenn da irgendwie auch immer alle Politiker und alle Beamte, die vielleicht gerade irgendwo hinfliegen, um irgendeinen Akta äh Vertrag auszuhandeln, ja dann äh auch einfach gepullt werden können, ne.
Um das jetzt noch ganz kurz deine zu der Frage, bei der ich gerade etwas gewackelt habe, zitiere ich jetzt nochmal die No-PNR-Webseite. Ähm also die,
EU verhandelt gerade mit den USA
über diese Übermittlung der Flugkastaten, darüber hinaus gibt's Pläne, Fluggastdaten auch von europäischen Flügen zu speichern, das heißt das äh geschieht im Moment noch nicht so
im Rat sowie im EU-Parlament wird auch die Auswertung von Fluggasdaten innereuropäischer Flüge sowie die Speicherung von Reiseinformationen anderer Verkehrsmittel wie der Bahn
diskutiert also es geht da auch in diesem Fall wieder darum, dass offensichtlich erstmal so ein,
was ist da des des.
Der Damm erstmal brechen soll oder was ist da die was ist da die Floskel, was ist da die.
Was du sagen willst, aber.
Ein Dammbruch, ein Dammbruch soll.
Sind hier auf jeden Fall äh ja breit.
Kehrsdaten deiner Reise werden sozusagen da erhoben.
Genau, ähm weshalb wir auch äh jetzt immer mehr von der Vorratsdatenspeicherung der Reisebewegungen gesprochen wird. Und ich denke, ähm das kann man auch so tatsächlich nennen.
Ja, jetzt haben wir ja schon gehört, dass auch hier Österreicher äh da eine Rolle spielen. Das ist natürlich eine wunderbare Überleitung hier zu unserem kleinen Spezial. Ähm.
Wir haben nicht so den Einblick, Thomas, aber du bist ja schon eine Weile dabei. Ähm und.
Vielleicht kannst du nochmal so einen kleinen Einblick geben, wie es denn konkret aussieht, ähm so mit dieser ganzen Entwicklung mit Netzpolitik und Österreich. Lange Zeit hat er mal so den Eindruck, egal was in Deutschland passiert, so in Österreich,
bestenfalls Echos.
Ja, den Eindruck hatte ich auch ganz lange,
ähm äh das war halt auch so, man hat lange versucht irgendwie, also wie ist die Situation? Natürlich bekommt man aus Deutschland mit, was hier passiert
ähm man kennt die ganzen Organisationen, man man weiß von den Themen, man liest dieselben Blocks, hört dieselben Podcasts und dann schaut man in sein eigenes Land und findet das da irgendwie
nicht nur ein Bruchteil davon passiert,
Und wenn man sich äh selbst engagieren will, wenn man irgendwie sieht, hey das sind wichtige Themen, wie kann ich denn wenigstens mal herausfinden, was in Österreich los ist? Du hast irgendwie in Deutschland wird das diskutiert und in Österreich spricht nicht mal jemand drüber,
Also das Netzpolitik in der Politik äh in den Parteien verankert ist. Davon sind wir immer noch weit entfernt.
Aber es hat sich halt doch so im letzten Jahr bissel was bewegt, also,
Für mich war so der Starting Point die Beschluss der Vorratsdatenspeicherung in Österreich damit hat sich viel bewegt,
und da wir haben auch einen Ackervorrat, der sich schon ähm einige Jahre davor gegründet hat und äh der,
halt versucht hat, immer wieder Stellungnahmen zu geben und halt eher so auf diesem Gesetzesprozess eingewirkt hat, aber jetzt nicht groß die Öffentlichkeit hatte oder auch nicht gesucht hat.
Sind diese AKV jetzt nur namensgleich, aber äh organisatorisch vollständig getrennt von der Bewegung in Deutschland.
Das ist ein eigener Verein, der den Namen gleich hat und sonst aber nichts gemeinsam hat. Also da gibt's natürlich äh irgendwie dasselbe Ziel. Dieses Gesetz abzuschaffen und auch die EU-Richtlinie zu bekämpfen, aber personell gibt's da keine Überschneidungen.
Was ist denn so der Ist-Zustand Vorratsdatenspeicherung in der österreichischen Gesetzgebung? Sind das schon so weit so ratifiziert und äh beschlossen, wie das äh Europa immer gefordert hat?
Ja, das ist es. Ähm lass mich chronologisch durchgehen
Also wir haben äh schon einen Vertragsverletzungsverfahren bekommen, also es wurde angedroht, weil wir diese Richtlinie
immer noch nicht umgesetzt hatten, haben sie vor, ich glaube, es war zweitausendneun oder zehn haben sie so mit den Säbeln geraspelt und gesagt, so, jetzt mach mal endlich.
Und dann ist so dieser schwarze Peter ständig hin und her gereicht worden und irgendwann hat man entschieden gut das Feld in die Zuständigkeit des Infrastrukturministeriums,
und dann ist da jemand zum Handkuss gekommen, der sich gedacht hat, äh also es war schon irgendwie bekannt, dass das eine heikle Materie ist und.
Infrastrukturministerium.
Verkehrsministerium.
Primär. Vorratsdatenspeicherung, Verkehrsminister.
Verkehrsministerin, ja. Ja, also.
Verkehrsministerin. Ja, okay. Muss man ja auch erst mal drauf kommen, ne? Es ist äh schon ganz gut. So, Verkehr, Datenverkehr, das passt.
Ähm also nicht Innenministerium, nicht Justizausschuss, äh Justizministerium, die zwei haben sich da danach zu Wort gemeldet, aber auf jeden Fall hat diese Ministerin die kluge Entscheidung getroffen, äh damit jemanden zu beauftragen.
Und lustigerweise äh jemanden, der ein bekannter Kritiker äh dieser EU-Richtlinie ist, nämlich dass Ludwig Bolzmann Institut für Menschenrechte. Kurz Bim, also.
Wurden womit konkret beauftragt.
Gesetz zu schreiben.
Das ist äh eine schon sehr, sehr altes und bekanntes Institut, die sich für Menschenrechte einsetzen. Äh die haben eine riesige Forschungsabteilung, machen immer wieder Studien.
Kannst du nochmal den Namen sagen?
Ludwig Bolzmann Institut für Menschenrechte, ja? Ähm sind in Österreich recht bekannt, also vor allem in der in der Wissenschaftsszene. Und.
Also das das Infrastrukturministerium sah sich gedrängt,
Die ganze Regierung sah sich gedrängt, die Vorratsdatenspeicherung nach EU-Vorgabe umzusetzen, hat es dann die Infrastrukturministerium zugeschoben und das hat sich dann an dieses Institut gewendet und sagt, macht ihr das doch mal.
So richtig schwarzer Peter. Ich will nicht Nimm Du. Nein, ich will auch nicht.
Institut für Menschenrechte wird mit der Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Ja. Beauftragt.
Noch dazu schon bekannte Kritiker waren, die schon eine Studie über die Deutsche Vorratsdaten.
Ist denn diese Ministerin auch als Kritikerin bekannt oder kann man jetzt davon ausgehen, dass sie nicht wusste, was sie tut.
Ich glaube jetzt weiteres. Also daher es war ihr schon bekannt, dass das ein heikles Thema ist, sonst hätte sie das nicht äh ausgelagert, aber äh ja, ist jetzt auch nicht so die große Netzpolitikerin, die Doris Boris, die das damals äh beauftragt hat,
Und äh wie gesagt, also das äh Ludwig Bolzmann Institut, die waren schon bekannte Kritiker, diese Richtlinie und die haben gleich von vorne rein gesagt, äh zwei Dinge,
Wir schreiben dieses Gesetz, aber wir machen's, äh also wir machen's zu verfassungsschonend wie es geht, verfassungskonform geht sowieso nicht,
Weißt du grundsätzliche Unstimmigkeiten gibt. Also das war das Credo, mit dem sie angefangen haben.
Ist auch nicht schlecht.
Und dann haben sie auch gesagt, dass sie sich natürlich das Rechts äh behalten, dieses Gesetz weiterhin zu kritisieren, auch wenn sie es geschrieben haben.
Und äh ja, da wurde hier ein Gesetz geschrieben,
auch ein wirklich Gutes, wie man sich denken könnte, also da gibt's äh einige Checks und Balance und äh wirklich auch,
da da wurde ja das ganze Telekommunikationsgesetz umgeschrieben und Teile des äh Strafgesetzbuches und des Sicherheitspolizeiverordnung, also schon die heiklen Bereiche
Wenn so um Datenauskünfte geht. Und äh was Verkehrsdaten sind, also im Kern ist es äh eine Minimalumsetzung der EU-Richtlinie
Das heißt, sie wird äh sechs Monate lang gespeichert, wer mit wem wie lange telefoniert hat, ähm
SMS geschickt hat oder MMS, von wo das passiert ist, ist auch die Standortdaten und natürlich der E-Mail-Verkehr genauso, wer, wann, wo mit wem,
und bei Internet wird nur der Zeitpunkt der Verbindung und die öffentliche IP-Adresse gespeichert. Sprich das erlaubt mir, wenn ich VIP-Adresse habe, auf die Stammdaten zu kommen, auf den Nutzer, der diesen Internetanschluss hat.
Wie lange soll die Speicherung sechs Monate, wie es eigentlich ursprünglich gefordert ist.
Ja, das ist so die minimalrichtlinie. Ich glaube, weniger geht auch nicht, damit man konform ist.
Ja und dann wurde das Ganze auch im Parlament verabschiedet und zwar ähm neunundzwanzigsten April zweitausendelf.
Und ja, ich war zu dem Zeitpunkt auch im Parlament und habe da ein bisschen davon berichtet. Wir haben da auch Diskussionsrunden gehabt gleich danach. Unter anderem auch mit ähm,
Ein Mitglied vom AK Vorrat, der auch im Ludwig Bolzmann-Institut sitzt und auch dort erste Reihe fußfrei, wie er sagt, dieses Gesetz geschrieben hat. Also wir haben auch im Ackervorrat Leute vom Ludwig Bolzmann Institut, die an diesem Gesetz mitgeschrieben haben.
Und äh ja.
Te-Reihe Fuß frei.
Er wurde halt wirklich damit beauftragt, das ist irgendwie ein Techniker, der auch juristisch und der bei diesem Institut arbeitet und ja, der hat.
In das erste Reihe fußfrei ist.
Ja, dass er halt wirklich von, ich schreibe dieses Gesetz bis hin zu ich verhandele mit ähm den verschiedenen Ministerien, ich verhandele mit der Rechteindustrie, die da lustigerweise auch teilweise am Tisch saß,
Und äh er, ja,
Dieses Gesetz tritt ab ersten April zweitausendzwölf in Kraft. Das heißt, das ist nicht mehr lange. Das steht schon vor der Tür und
Ja, wir haben uns dann im Oktober ähm so ja da ist dazwischen noch ein bissel was passiert, also es war schon so, dass die dass der Acker vorher da immer mehr Zulauf bekommen hat von jungen Leuten vor allem
und dass da immer mehr Leute angedockt sind, die gesagt haben, so jetzt machen wir was. Es wird Zeit. Es ist wichtig,
und ähm dann wurden diese Diskussionsrunden äh immer produktiver und dann gab's irgendwann einmal im September diese E-Mail von jemandem zu. Wir haben hier im Parlament das neue
neue Möglichkeit, Bürgerinitiativen und Petitionen auch online zu unterstützen. Also das, was ihr auf der Bundestagspetitionsseite habt, bekamen wir auch,
Und dann haben wir sofort gesagt, gut, das machen wir,
Wir schreiben jetzt mal irgendwas bis nächste Woche haben wir den Text und dann reichen wir hier eine Bürgerinitiative ein. Bürgerinitiative hat die niedrigste Hürde. Vielleicht schaffen wir diese fünfhundert Unterschriften, die wir da brauchen in zwei Monaten
nehmen wir uns Zeit, fangen wir niedrig an, weil uns war klar, dass unser Thema wichtig ist, aber ob's hier eine breitere Öffentlichkeit gibt, das war.
Fünfhundert Unterschriften in zwei Monaten.
Ja, wir haben.
Für eine Online-Petition.
Ja, die fünfhundert brauchtest du, damit du online kommst. Die fünfhundert,
auf Papier und dann kannst du erst online machen und wir haben uns gedacht, online, da werden wir dann aber, da schaffen wir es vielleicht vierstellig zu werden.
Also das war der Anfang und auch so viel zum Selbstbewusstsein der Netzpolitik in Österreich zu diesem Zeitpunkt
Ja und dann haben wir angefangen. Also wir haben eine Bürgerinitiative geschrieben für die Abschaffung der EU-Richtlinie zur Vorratsdatenspeicherung und zu evaluieren sämtlicher Terrorgesetze.
Also Evaluierung der Terrorgesetze, man soll mal nachschauen, ob die ähm verhältnismäßig sind und überhaupt den Zweck erfüllen. Also auch eine handzahme Forderung im Grunde.
Also auch Gesetze, die wahrscheinlich alle im Nachgang zu den Anschlägen von Nane Eleven gekommen sind.
Nine eleven. Genau, ja. Also, dass man da nochmal drüber geht und wissenschaftlich schaut, äh, sind die überhaupt zu konform und notwendig?
Weißt du zufällig, ob da, ob die Gesetze seiner Zeit auch äh also mit so einem Zeitvorbehalt ähm beschlossen wurden, ob da auch so eine Überprüfung irgendwann mit vorgesehen war oder es einfach so beschlossen worden ist, ist jetzt so.
Also es gibt bei der Vorratsdatenspeicherung gibt zu einem Maßnahme, weil auch die EU-Richtlinie natürlich schon im Wanken war, als wir das beschlossen haben,
aber generell bei sicherheitspolizeigesetzen machen wir das glaube ich nicht, zumindest wär's mir nicht bekannt,
Man hört auf jeden Fall nichts drüber. Also Diskussion gibt's da keinem. Und ja, wie gesagt, die die Erwartungen waren niedrig und am ersten Tag haben wir gleich hundertfünfzig Unterschriften zusammen gehabt.
In der ersten Woche hatten wir die fünfhundert, die wir eigentlich brauchen,
bis wir dann am vierzehnten Dezember ins Parlament gelaufen sind, um diese Bürgerinitiative zu übergeben mit mehreren Aktenordnern, hatten wir schon viertausendvierhunderteinundsiebzig Unterschriften aus Papier.
Da war noch gar nichts online. Das heißt, man muss auch diese zwei Monate abwarten.
Wir haben uns gedacht, das war so hier, schickt uns die Briefe und da war eine Frist dabei und wir wollten uns an die Frist halten,
irgendwie nicht Leute danach noch Briefe schicken und wir können die nicht mehr ja nicht mehr einreichen. Die Stimme wäre dann irgendwie verloren.
Ähm da kam aber auch wirklich Briefe aus ganz Österreich. Also wirklich aus dem hintersten Bergkampf, also
Hintertucs war auch dabei. Und wirklich alte Leute, die ähm einzelne Unterschriften ausgefüllt haben und auch das Kuvert beschriftet. Sprich, da war Einundsechzigjähriger, der das Thema wichtig findet und das,
äh als als einzelnen Brief losschickt an uns. Also das Interesse war da schon riesig groß,
Und als wir dann gestartet haben mit der Onlinephase, das war so Ende Dezember,
zeichnen mit AT war die Plattform, die wir dafür verwendet haben und innerhalb der ersten vierundzwanzig Stunden hatten wir zehntausend neue Unterschriften.
Das war mal so,
Ja, jetzt äh das war im Ende der Dezember und obwohl da irgendwie Weihnachten dazwischen war und jetzt schon viel passiert ist, äh wir stehen im Moment so bei äh jetzt gerade zweiundsiebzigtausendfünfhundert,
und die Kurve wächst immer noch und zweiundsiebzigtausend damit hätte echt niemand gerechnet. Äh wir haben uns.
Für unsere Deutschen mal kleine äh Erdung ähm Österreich hat wie viele Millionen Einwohner?
Acht Millionen. Wir sind ein Zehntel Deutschlands und wir haben trotzdem eben.
Ähnliche Petitionsergebnisse. Ihr habt, ihr habt im Prinzip in in Österreich äh mehr ähm mehr Unterschriften gegen die Vorratsdatenspeicherung als Deutschland bisher gegen Acta hat bei zehnmal so vielen Einwohnern.
Exakt. Und das ist auch.
Nur mal den Erfolg mal so in in die Relations.
Ja und das aber auch ohne ohne netzpolitische Medien, ohne groß, wir haben kein Netzpolitik Punkt org, wir haben kein CCC, wir haben da eine ganz andere Struktur, was so die Internetmedien betrifft, trotzdem hat das Irrsinn nicht gut gefruchtet. Und.
Oder vielleicht auch gerade deswegen.
Ja, ich glaube, die Leute sind auch ausgehungert gewesen
Auf jeden Fall äh wir wir hatten sogar äh die vierundsechzigtausendsiebenhundertfünf, das was das Maximal war der Deutschen Vorratsdatenspeicherungspetition war unser Cordoba zwei Punkt null. Als wir es geschafft haben, euch auch absolut einzuholen.
Es ist immer noch nicht vergessen.
Nein, niemals.
Oh Gott. Wir sollten mehr mit Fußballanalogien arbeiten.
Oh nein, ich bin da nicht dafür.
Ja, also was was macht man mit ähm zweiundsiebzigtausend Unterschriften
wir waren am zwölften März da war zum ersten Mal so ein Petitionsausschuss,
ähm und da waren wir Tagesordnungspunkt, äh lass mich lügen, neunundzwanzig von fünfzig und wir hatten so ungefähr zweieinhalb Minuten Zeit, behandelt zu werden dort. Sie haben aber entschieden, dass sie uns äh einladen wollen zum,
wir haben selbst das Recht, dort zu sprechen, im Petitionsausschuss,
und das Problem ist halt, dass wir jetzt so in einer wir wir kommen in so eine Verzögerungstaktik rein, weil der nächste Ausschuss ist erst am einunddreißigsten Mai,
Das heißt, wir können dieses Ding ja nicht beenden. Das läuft so lange. Man kann so lange sammeln, bis der Petitionsausschuss das Anliegen,
An andere Ausschüsse weiterleitet. Also in unserem Fall, wir wollen.
War, es gibt keine offizielle Deadline und dann wird's bewertet, sondern das können die einfach so, ach ihr habt erst zweihunderttausend Unterschriften, da geht doch bestimmt noch was, das lassen wir nochmal ein Jahr laufen. Das ist ja auch.
Leider, ja. Also ich würde mir da auch irgendwie langsam so einen Cut wünschen, dass man irgendwie sagt, so über die Zeit haben wir so viel geschafft. Und jetzt machen wir was damit. Aber.
Kannst du dir einen Brief schreiben und sagen irgendwie, wenn er das jetzt nicht mal, wenn er das jetzt nicht mal annehmt, dann kommt dann jeder mal kurz vorbei und sagt hallo.
Sagt hallo. Ja, wir können das Parlament die Dorssen vielleicht.
Demonstrationen, ne.
Ähm jetzt ist aber die Situation halt, wir wir haben auf jeden Fall noch bis Ende Mai, einunddreißigster Mai und ich wir hoffen halt, dass wir bis dahin,
dass sie bis dahin wissen, was sie mit uns tun sollen. Ich im Grunde ist es klar, jetzt haben sie noch Stellungnahmen eingeholt und wollen irgendwie Expertise dazu zählen, aber im Grunde wäre es so klar, was man jetzt machen müsste. Also man muss ähm,
Es ist ja sowieso schon so, dass Österreich eigentlich die Vorratsdatenspeicherung auf EU-Ebene nie so gutgeheißen hat. Man müsste sich jetzt nur klar dagegen aussprechen,
und anfangen, diese Terrorgesetze zu evaluieren, also,
Vorschläge gemacht, dass man Technik voll und Abschätzungsinstitut dazuzieht und die mal fragt, wie evoluiert man ein Gesetz, was das Internet betrifft. Ähm ich glaube auch, dass teilweise noch gar nicht das Bewusstsein oder die Instrumente da sind, um damit richtig umzugehen.
Aber wir würden ihnen helfen, wenn sie halt anfangen, diesen Diskurs zu führen und äh ja,
wir sind jetzt sozusagen nochmal auf die lange Bank gelegt, aber wir sammeln auch immer noch weiterhin Unterschriften, also die Kurve flacht nicht so ab, also.
Hm, vielleicht mal so ein bisschen allgemeiner gesprochen. Ich meine, wir hatten ja hier so äh so diesen Zensursolar-Moment, ne, wo sich das alles so ein bisschen äh kulminiert hat und seitdem steht irgendwie kein Stein mehr auf dem anderen. Ähm jetzt so ein so ein so ein
so ein konkretes Ereignis gab's jetzt in Österreich eigentlich so nicht, oder? Wie schätzt du denn, dass du überhaupt so
ein. Ich meine, hier wird jetzt so mit Piratenpartei, ne, man wird sehen, wie die nächsten Landtagswahlen ausgehen, aber es ist halt so, ich will jetzt nicht so von von Wechselstimmung reden, aber
es tut sich was so, ja? Äh deutsche äh Politkörper, der hat schon so Bedenken, was das Aufkommen betrifft und Netzpolitik ist so als als Politik-Genre jetzt auf einmal so,
äh aufgenommen worden, inwieweit das wirklich ernst genommen wird oder man nur versucht da einem Trend zu begegnen, ist er jetzt mal dahin gestellt, wie äh bildet sich das gerade in äh Österreich ab? Spielt das in den öffentlichen Medien eine Rolle oder ist das einfach immer noch Undercover?
Wie siehst du das äh auch so bei der bei der Jugend? Was was passiert da?
Also ich würde sagen, wir haben, wir haben langsam Netzpolitiker, Netzpolitikerinnen in Österreich, also es gibt einzelne Politiker, auch in großen Parteien, die versuchen, sich dieses Themas anzunehmen, aber als Polit
Bereich, als als Thema oder ähm als eigene Kategorie in den Zeitungen oder sowas, ist es noch lange nicht angekommen,
Also es fehlt noch das Selbstverständnis äh in den Parteien. Es fehlt noch ähm dieses Genre, über das man reden könnte, Internetpolitik.
Natürlich gibt's einzelne Medien, die das äh so im Technologiebereich abhandeln, aber ähm
das bildet sich alles, also da war auch Acta wichtig, diese großen Demonstrationen, wir hatten zweimal zehntausend Leute auf der Straße und es bildet sich so langsam heraus,
Wir haben auch äh also wie gesagt, wir haben so die einzelnen zivilgesellschaftlichen NGOs, die jetzt so langsam anfangen aufzuwachen. Da ist die Initiative für Netzfreiheit, die aus Expiraten besteht, die wirklich viel machen.
Der Verein für Internetbenutzer, die auch diese PNR-Kampagne machen und ganz stark hinter AKV stehen, also von denen kommen die ganzen Ressourcen und Leiter.
Und das sind so die zwei, die im Moment am aktivsten sind und dann noch die Quintessenz, die auch wichtig ist für das, was sie tut. Ähm wir haben auch Piraten.
Muss man vielleicht auch noch dazu sagen. Ist ja wirklich auch eine der ältesten Institutionen eigentlich in äh Österreich, die sich so dieser Themenlage annimmt.
Die sind auch ähm so ein Fels in der Brandung, fordern seit ähm weiß Gott wie vielen Jahren schon ähm die Wiederherstellung der Bürgerrechte im digitalen Zeitalter,
und äh die
sind halt auch, also ich, ich sehe, ich habe so persönlich immer mein Problem gehabt, dass es äh sehr schwierig ist, Zugang zu finden zu diesen Organisationen und sich ähm jetzt mal für ein Thema aktiv dort zu engagieren. Die haben halt auch das Problem, dass sie irgendwie so verkrustete ähm Strukturen sind,
eher eine alte Männerpartie sind. Also was nicht gut funktioniert, ist das zu verjüngen. Und da mit motivierten jungen Leuten zusammenzuarbeiten. Aber ich finde, die braucht es halt auch, äh das ist das Boot, was zur Zeit diese ganze Bewegung am Laufen hält.
Und ähm,
Ja, wenn wir von jungen Leuten reden, wir haben auch äh eine Piratenpartei und ich glaube auch, dass generell der Erfolg der Piraten in Deutschland hier äh schon,
starke Auswirkungen auch in Österreich hat. Also ich weiß dann so von Klub Leuten, die zu,
Netzpolitikern gehen und so. Du aber das Ding mit dem Piraten. Du kümmerst dich da eh drum, oder?
Was ist denn das eigentlich? Also es kommt an, ja, die diese Wahlen, äh, die Berlin-Wahl, die war schon was und wenn jetzt irgendwie hier weiter vorgelegt wird, das hilft dem Thema sicherlich,
und das ist gut. Es geht mir auch um die Themen, ich bin nicht sehr äh also ich versuche immer Parteiunabhängig zu sein, mit allen zu reden aufgrund ihrer Aussagen nicht, welche Farbe sie haben,
die Piraten in Österreich sind halt noch ein bisschen sehr chaotisch und da muss ich meiner Meinung nach auch noch viel herausbilden und die müssen auch noch erwachsen werden, damit sie
auch so wirklich als als Kraft anfangen können, Wahlen zu gewinnen. Also ich finde sie im Moment so ist es gut, dass es sie gibt, aber sie haben noch einen langen Weg vor sich,
und.
Der kann äh wie sich in Deutschland zeigt, auch sehr schnell auf einmal sehr kurz werden dieser Weg. Also ähm ich würde sagen, dass äh wahrscheinlich sechs bis acht Monate vor
dem Einzug in Berlin so gut wie neunzig Prozent der Leute über über die Piratenpartei genau das gleiche gesagt haben, dass sie noch einen weiten Weg vor sich hat und ähm,
der kann mitunter sehr schnell gegangen werden.
Ich denke auch, man kann da sich eigentlich auch nur reinstürzen. Ich meine, immer so dieses Abwarten, na ja, wir müssen jetzt noch drei Jahre reifen. Ich meine, was soll da passieren? Da stellt man sich, dann setzt man sich dann vors Terminal und liest weiter äh Webseiten. Ja, also ich denke
das Engagement muss wahrscheinlich auch wirklich einfach stattfinden so. Man muss dann einfach da reingeworfen werden. Ich meine
fällt mir schwer jetzt so die Ergebnisse der nächsten Landtagswahlen äh vorherzusagen. Ja, wir haben jetzt äh Saarland, äh Schleswig-Holstein und dann NRW in in schneller Folge. NRW ist natürlich,
sagen wir mal so, dass das Zünglein an der Waage an der Stelle äh nicht nur jetzt generell für die Bundespolitik, aber auch sagen wir mal für die Piraten, selbst wenn's jetzt im Saarland oder im Schleswig-Holstein nicht reicht
würde es da halt klappen, das wäre definitiv 'ne Änderung, zumal davon auszugehen, dass das halt so die alte sogenannte Freiheitsorientierte Partei äh die FDP,
vermutlich einfach mit Ach und Krach aus allem rausfliegen wird, wo sie nicht sowieso schon drin ist. Ähm wo sie nicht sowieso schon draußen ist,
und äh ja, dann dann sind die Karten wahrscheinlich auch wirklich nochmal komplett neu gemischt.
Also wenn sie sich irgendwie ähm mehr zerlegt, wird Democracy bekennen würden oder es auch wirklich aktiv einsetzen würden und ein bissel mehr wirklich thematisch auch in netzpolitischen Themen arbeiten und und nicht nur laut sind, dann wenn ich's auf jeden Fall gut,
aber wie gesagt äh womit wollen wir jetzt eigentlich weitermachen? Ich hätt noch was Wichtiges zu.
Wir müssen's vor allem mal ähm abrunden, das Thema. Also,
Was jetzt mir klar geworden ist, ist so die Dinge sind in Bewegung und in gewisser Hinsicht könnte es jetzt jederzeit knallen
Ja, ist auch hier gab's halt so die ein oder andere Petition hat die Sache so äh in Schwung gebracht und
ganz unerwartet kommen dann immer wieder so Steigerungsstufen, wo es dann wieder auf einmal hochschießt, wo es gar nicht gereicht hat und das Feld scheint ein bisschen bestellt zu sein in Österreich. Das ist das, was ich jetzt aus dem rauslese, was du da so
von dir gibst, ne?
Ich würde noch kurz so was so unmittelbar noch bevor steht, ist wir haben natürlich eine Demo am einunddreißigsten März gegen die Vorratsdatenspeicherung Tag bevor sie in Kraft tritt gegen VDS RTs, die Homepage, die man sich da anschauen will,
und was wir auch planen ist eine Verfassungsklage gegen das Gesetz, weil,
Bürgerinitiative richtet sich ja nur auf die europäische Ebene und wir haben schon einen Verfassungstext geschrieben, also eine Verfassungsklage geschrieben, wo wir dann auch Ende, Ende März online gehen damit und da versuchen auch wieder viele Unterstützer zu kriegen,
und es geht halt jetzt irgendwie drum, dass das Thema weiter am köcheln bleibt und dass man so Vorratsdatenspeicherung sind, ein schöner, an dem man mal durch kann, wie Netzpolitik funktioniert. Im Grunde geht's natürlich um mehr.
Ich kann nur jeden sagen, der sich dafür interessiert. Ähm ich habe weil ich halt auch selbst sehr lange gesucht habe. Es gibt halt eben jetzt Organisationen, wo man sich engagieren kann oder informieren kann,
und die sind findbar, die verlinken wir auch und es ist halt einfach,
ähm klar, das ist jetzt ein Thema und das muss ein Thema bleiben und ähm ich bin selbst auch sehr begeistert, dass es auf einmal Leute gibt, die sich darum kümmern.
Ich hätte noch so viel mehr Themen. Ich hätte irgendwie noch überreden wollen oder ähm sie haben da auch noch so einen Fall gehabt.
Ja, im Moment jetzt ganz ruhig,
ähm so Vorratsdatenspeicherung in Österreich abgeschlossen. So, jetzt jetzt erzählst du uns noch kurz was zu Akta, würde ich sagen. Äh wie es da gelaufen ist.
Weil was äh was ich ja ganz interessant finde ist, was Tim gerade sagte, es gibt diese ähm,
Punkte, an denen auch vielleicht sehr überraschend Themen sehr enorm hochkochen, das ist jetzt offensichtlich Vorratsdatenspeicherung, da der Fall und ähm ActA war ja so ein Thema, was in ähm Deutschland nämlich,
uns auch so ein bisschen überrascht hatte, äh wie gut das wie gut das Thema innerhalb sehr kurzer Zeit dann doch ähm,
in Anführungszeichen hochgekocht ist, während wir vorher ähm es ja jahrelang so ein bisschen vernachlässigt hatten,
und ähm da kannst du uns doch durchaus nochmal erzählen, wie die Perspektive auf Acta so jetzt in Österreich war. Da Akte allerdings im Moment so viel
Thema äh ist, weil Lokbuch-Netzpolitik würde ich sagen, versuchen wir es ein bisschen kürzer zu halten, um mal so ein bisschen zu hören, wie das da in Österreich gelaufen ist, finde ich auf jeden Fall wichtig.
Ja, also wir hatten auch ähm zwei Akteame, so am elften Februar und fünfundzwanzigsten Februar. Ah, da waren auch jeweils insgesamt in Österreich so um die zehntausend Leute ähm auf der Straße. Darunter auch wirklich viele junge Leute, viele Gesichter, die man noch nicht gesehen hat.
Zehntausend Euro Leute für Österreich ist auch eine ganze Menge oder ist das.
Ja, das ist auch wieder so wir hatten größere Demos, damals bei den Studentenprotesten oder wie Haider an die Macht gekommen ist, aber so für so ein Thema ist, zehn.
Bei, wie viele Gast bei Haider?
Äh kennst du den hellen Platz, da wo äh
Weißt du, der Platz zwischen und den Regierungsgebäuden, der ist wirklich, wirklich groß. Da hatte Hitler seine Rede beim Anschluss und der war fast zur Gänze gefüllt, so dass die Regierung beim Antreten einen Tunnel nehmen musste,
Um vom Bundespräsidenten angelobt zu werden.
Okay, der ist echt ziemlich groß, ja. Ich vermisse hier grade mal an.
Das, das haben wir nicht erreicht.
Braucht man mehr als zehntausend Leute, ja. Okay, alles klar. Nur mal so so, dass äh die Zahlen immer ins Verhältnis zu setzen.
Ja, ohne Brenn waren, glaube ich, hunderttausend Leute, so die Studentenproteste,
Und äh jetzt hatten wir da zehntausend, wobei auch in Wien, glaube ich, waren's einmal viereinhalb, dann mal dreieinhalbtausend. Aber wir haben natürlich auch andere Städte,
wurde dort auch auf die Straße gegangen sind,
und das waren halt auch wirklich eben andere Leute, so die die transparente hatten teilweise sehr viele Mähmanspielungen, einen guten Witz und haben auch wirklich
die Sache auf den Punkt gebracht. Eines meiner Lieblinge ist immer noch, lasst unser Internet in Ruhe oder wir nehmen euch die Fax-Geräte weg.
Ja, das ist.
Den habe ich auch gesehen.
Das ist echt ein übler, übler Erklärung. Da musst du dich nicht wundern, wenn du dann irgendwann deine IFG-Anfragen scheitern wegen Gewaltdrogen, ne.
Und ähm bei uns kam's dann auch dazu, also kurz vor der zweiten Akte, die immer hat, unsere Regierung auch gemeint, na wir legen das mal auf Eis,
wir warten auch mal, was die EU tut. Da waren ja schon vorher schon ähm zuerst Polen äh Slowenien äh,
Slowakei und äh Deutschland und Österreich hat sich da eben auch recht spät so als fünfter in die Reihe gestellt und gesagt, nee, acta machen wir jetzt zumindest mal nicht. Da gab's auch wirklich viele Stellungnahmen von,
Arbeiterkammer von Journalistenclub, von vielen Institutionen, die auf einmal das Thema gesehen haben,
auch so in Bezug auf Netzpolitik äh wird in den Diskurs wichtig, ein Punkt des Dienst äh herauszustreichen gilt
und äh natürlich kann man jetzt nicht ewig stehen bleiben und über Aktor sprechen, weil eigentlich geht's natürlich ums Urheberrecht. Und das Problem, was das Urheberrecht mit dem Internet hat.
Und da wollen wir im Moment auch hin mit dem Diskurs. Also sprich, es geht jetzt drum, dass wir,
ernsthaft anfangen, Diskurs zu führen, über das Urheberrecht und der soll halt eben auch Nutzer beinhalten, Provider beinhalten, Künstler und Kulturschaffende beinhalten. Und wenn's sein muss, auch die Rechte für Werte, aber.
Viel viel Spaß äh beim Verfolgen dieses Planes. Ich glaube, da.
Leider wir haben so wir wir haben mal Impulse gesetzt.
Ja. Ja, ist ja sehr wichtig.
Können ja nicht ohne sie diskutieren. Es es hilft uns gerade sehr, dass die Verwertungsindustrie äh eine Sockpuppe gestartet hat mit dem Namen Kunst hat Recht.
Ach, das war, ja genau, der Leonard hatte das, glaube ich, auch bei Netzpolitik auch Kunst hat recht. Und dann gab's die, was war.
Überwachung.
Kunst gegen Überwachung, ja.
Also es gab gleich mehrere Gegenvereinigungen. Also was die da getan haben war, wir haben, sie haben eine Homepage gemacht, äh wo wo sie irgendwie so den den armen Künstler nach vorne stellen, der wegen dem bösen Internet kein Geld mehr verdient,
Also die das klassische Clarks Lied, was wir eh schon alle schon kennen,
Im Impressum stand dann irgendwie die gesamte Verwerterindustrie Österreichs und äh gemanagt hat den ganzen Auftrag, eine Lobbyfirma, die sich auf die Fahnen schreibt, besonders bei Problemthemen gut zu sein,
Also man musste irgendwie recht leicht was da recht schnell was davon zu erwarten ist. Äh darunter waren auch so Schmankerl wie irgendwie eine eine ähm Bildhauerin, die Angst vorm Internet hat
Also wir wir haben das dann so verstanden, dass vielleicht drei D Drucker ja Angst machen.
Ja, der kann, das können die sich auch irgendwann abschminken, ihre äh Bildhauerei, wenn wenn wir erstmal den Granitdrucker entworfen haben,
dann äh können die einpacken.
Ja, ist eine tolle Webseite, ein Blog mit genau einem Post.
Da geht's richtig ab, würde ich sagen.
Ja und das Interessanteste war halt auch, dass sie dann sehr stark aus der Kunst und Kulturszene, die in Österreich sehr stark ist, kritisiert wurden.
Dass man da auch irgendwie entdeckt hat, äh die Forderungen, die die da stellen, sind gar nicht so in unserem Interesse. Und das Problem ist nicht so einfach, wie sie es formulieren
Und ähm da gab's schon zig Diskussionsrunden und es gibt immer noch welche. Ähm vielleicht finde ich ein paar, auf die wir da auch verlinken können,
Auf jeden Fall ähm ist es gerade so irgendwie ein gescheitertes Projekt, aber was es natürlich,
was Gutes ist, dass man ja zu über Urheberrecht spricht. Und das ist auch so eines der nächsten Themen, die wir auch in Küchen lassen. Ähm ja, köcheln lassen wollen.
Heißt, ihr habt also eine große, breite Debatte über äh urheberrecht gibt es in der Form jetzt erstmal in Österreich noch nicht so,
in Deutschland muss man ja wirklich sagen, die ist inzwischen schon ähm.
Angekommen, diese Debatte, ne, dass die überall geführt wird. Hauptsächlich natürlich auch äh ja, forciert, ähnlich wie jetzt bei euch. Natürlich eher durch die äh Rechteverwerter als durch die ähm progressiven Kräfte.
Na ja, es ist so ein Battle, also wann immer eine Diskussion stattfindet. Es es passiert sehr dezentral. Also wir haben da in verschiedenen Städten, von verschiedenen äh Gruppe
aus, die auch teilweise gar nicht netzpolitisch sind, sondern eben wirklich aus diesem Kunstkultursegment kommen oder äh vom Providerseite sind, ähm
oder wirklich so aus der Verwehrterindustrie kommen. Die fangen alle an, irgendwie über dieses Thema zu reden. Man begleitet den Diskurs sozusagen und versucht auch Vorschläge zu machen,
Also gerade, was wir so immer wieder gerne in Diskurs werfen, ist das äh Kulturwerkmarktmodell vom CCC.
Und auch flettern, Micropayment, Social Payment, all diese Dinge werden ja gute Lösungen oder zumindest Dinge, die man mal diskutieren muss
Und ja, da beschäftigen wir uns mit und das ist halt auch so eins dieser Standbahne.
So und dann hattest du noch ähm als weiteren Punkt, den du mal ansprechen wolltest, das Vorgehen gegen ein mutmaßlichen enormen Aktivisten von enormem Austria.
Ja. Ähm muss Österreich oder auch Aaron Austria,
Ah, die gibt's schon einiger Zeit und die, ja, die machen Dinge. Also, kennt man ja, An- und Ausdreher ist,
halt dir der österreichische Ableger davon, der auch ein bissel so ein Alleinstellungsanspruch äh für sich einnimmt, also der sagt irgendwie wir sind, äh bei niemand anderer.
Und äh Jan.
Das ist schwierig bei enorm ist. Wenn man, wenn man das so machen möchte, das sollte äh schwer sein bei einer Gruppe, die anonym ist und wo jeder mitmachen kann, zu sagen, wie.
Es gibt den Twitter-Account, es gibt den IAC-Channel, also die klassischen Informationsstrukturen und äh die,
Die haben halt irgendwie angefangen und und äh schon von ähm Hacker Cracker Seite ordentlich was vorgelegt am Anfang. Also sie haben äh die Daten der Kiss geliebt. GIS ist sowas wie die ähm
Sagt man dazu, wenn du einen Fernseher hast oder Radio musst du's dort anmelden.
Erinnere mich.
Ja? Da haben sie.
Her oder so, ne?
Genau, da haben sie auch irgendwie ähm personenbezogene Daten rausgegeben von sehr vielen Leuten, ähnlich wie sie das auch bei,
Datenbank der internationalen Policeation gemacht haben, äh sprich sie haben sich ernsthaft getraut, die persönlichen Daten von einer riesigen Menge vom Polizisten offen ins Netz zu stellen,
was natürlich bei der Polizei nicht besonders auch viel Gegenliebe stößt. Genauso haben sie auch irgendwie mehrere Parteiseiten, die faced und das hat alles halt dazu geführt, dass die Polizei tätig wird.
Und ähm gab's diesen Fall, wo wo das, was ich auch ausstreichen will, mehr oder weniger die Art und Weise ist, wie sie da versucht haben, äh,
Ja, im Internet zu zu recherchieren und äh und eine Internetuntersuchung zu führen. Man könnte fast glauben, das war das erste Mal, dass die österreichische Polizei so was jemals getan hat.
Ah, dann wird's bestimmt eine lustige Geschichte, die du uns jetzt erzählst.
Ja. Er wird es.
Ähm also kurz noch als Pre-Face dazu. Es ähm gibt da diesen, diesen äh angeblichen, ähm der
im Oktober einige Nazis losgelassen hat,
Ganze Untersuchung ähm wird nämlich auch offiziell mit der Begründung geführt, dass es äh hier ums Wiederbetätigungsgesetz geht oder Verbotsgesetz, sprich,
dass da irgendwie die Verfolgung oder die die Verfolgung von der Verherrlichung von Nazi Verbrechen ähm der Fall ist,
Auf jeden Fall ähm war das so der der Grund, wieso die Polizei ihr letztendlich tätig wurde und dann,
Haben sie versucht irgendwie mehrere Leute auszuforschen und zuerst mal mit denen angefangen, die ein Nicken im hatten, über den sie ausgeforscht werden konnten und äh da haben sie auch irgendwie Leute von uns erwischt.
Die Sicherheit mit Netzpolitik beschäftigen, aber eben äh eigentlich nicht Teil von sind, aber halt natürlich mit denen sich informieren müssen, was da los ist, vor allem bei den Demos, ist ja noch nicht muss bei uns ein ganz starker Faktor, also die mobilisieren sehr viel.
Und ähm da wurden halt Leute zu Zeugeneinvernahmen geladen und was man da schon irgendwie gemerkt hat, sie haben ganz stark nach Ideologie gefragt. Also wie stehen sie zu dieser Gruppe? Was halten sie von?
Ähm.
Das ist ja eine relativ blöde Frage, weil es geht doch wahrscheinlich keiner zur Polizei und erzählt den Jahr hier äh in Ordnung ist, finde ich super,
oder ich fand's echt besonders gut, als die euch gehackt haben und fünfundzwanzigtausend Polizisten Daten online gestellt haben so. Das wird ja ähm.
Was sie damit erreichen wollten, waren mir nicht klar. Ich glaube, sie haben halt so irgendwie versucht, mal an diesen Komplex und diese neue Art von Struktur, ja, sich heranzutasten, genau.
Das stellt natürlich auch Ermittler und als ich die die Struktur wie sich ähm organisiert und agiert,
stellt natürlich auch, sage ich mal, tradierte Ermittlungsmethoden und Vorstellungen von politischem Aktivismus äh durchaus vor ähm,
vor vor Schwierigkeiten, dass man irgendwie ähm,
wenn es wenn diese Gruppen denn dann tatsächlich so flach in ihrer Hierarchie bleiben, es hat sich ja eigentlich dann gezeigt,
dann doch nicht so ist, ne? Dass sich da doch auch jetzt bei im und Antisek und Umfeld dann doch irgendwie da äh Führer äh in einer gewissen Form.
Letztendlich etablieren, also diese diese Dezentralität ähm stellt oder vor allem dieses dieser lose Zusammenschluss stellt einerseits,
Ermittlungsansätze ein bisschen auf die Probe oder stellt ihnen Schwierigkeiten andererseits auf Dauer dann auch nicht, weil sich da irgendwie so eine,
Autoarchivgenese einstellt, dass dann eben doch wieder äh sich Hierarchien ausbilden oder so. Aber okay, sehr interessant ähm,
Sie haben also dann random Leute eingeladen und nach ihrer Gesinnung befragt,
sehr vielversprechender Ansatz. Ähm Austria kann wahrscheinlich jetzt einparken, oder?
Äh also ob sie damit Jever überhaupt irgendwie in die Nähe gekommen sind, äh,
lasse ich mal so stehen, aber was sie dann es dann halt getan haben, war, dass sie sich jemanden rausgesucht haben, den sie gefunden haben, aufgrund des Facebookbildes. Also nochmal, der Nickname, nachdem sie gesucht haben, wartet,
Und sie haben jemanden gefunden, der in Facebook-Profilfoto hatte von sich, wo er halt so its the ute. Mit Anspielung auf dem Film Big Le Bonski.
So sind sie auf diesen Michael R gekommen, der da ins Fadenkreuz gelangt ist und der, der ist halt aus der IT-Branche, aus der,
glaube ich Security-Umfeld,
und sie haben dann halt, äh ich verlinke die Dokumente, elf Punkte rausgesucht, wo sowas drin steht, wie er ist im Besitz einer IRC E-Mail-Adresse.
Krass. Ich nicht.
Sowas wollte ich auch schon mal haben.
Ja, also es war halt auch ähm sein Nicknehmen äh Punkt Punkt äh äh IAC Punkt com und,
falsch. Natürlich war das keine E-Mail-Adresse und das war so eins der Punkte und sonst haben sie auch vor allem Twitter verwendet. Äh sie nannten das, glaube ich, Open-Source-Recherche und haben dort solche Dinge wie er unterhält sich mit anderen Leuten auf technisch hohem Niveau,
und äh Verschleierung von Ausdrucken, weil die Leute irgendwie über die IFFF Liste geredet haben mit mit Druckern, die man nicht nachvollziehen äh nachverfolgen kann,
und ja, viele weitere Punkte, die, wenn man sich durchlest, ähm, es sind auch kommentiert in diesem Dokumenten, alle irgendwie ein recht gutes Bild zeigen, wie die Polizei so ermittelt
Da gab's auf jeden Fall eine Hausdurchsuchung und nachdem sie da nichts gefunden hatten, wurde das Verfahren im Grunde eh auch schnell eingestellt. Und äh,
ja, im Grunde kann man festhalten, dass die,
Die Amtshandlung zu einem Rahmen war, also sie haben das dann recht schnell fallen lassen, als sie gesehen haben, dass da nichts ist. In zumindest nicht im Nazibereich,
aber wie's dazu gekommen ist und wie die Polizei hier Beschuldigte auswählt, ist natürlich höchstgradig gefährlich, vor allem wenn man dann anfängt,
netzpolitischen Aktivismus auch so unter subsummieren, macht man einfach 'n gravierenden Fehler der Demokratie politisch sehr bedenklich ist.
Ja im Grunde, das sind zwei Leute, die ihren Anwaltskosten sitzen geblieben, aber sie haben es auch mit äh der Veröffentlichung dieser Dokumente und ein paar parlamentarischen Anfragen versucht wieder auszugleichen.
Und natürlich gibt's Österreich noch, also da hat sich, glaube ich, keine Schramme gezeigt.
Mhm. Und dieser doode äh war einem Anschein nach offensichtlich sehr unschuldig und hatte gar nichts mit dem Verein zu tun.
Nee, der tut, das war schon ihr Adminord, also der war ein Nonne muss äh ihr C Server Admin und scheint da auch irgendwie viel gepostet zu haben und laut den Jetlocks hat er da auch wirklich irgendwie Sachen gesagt,
die äh von der Aussage ja zumindest grenzwertig sind, was Verbotsgesetze angeht und und,
sicherlich nicht gut geheißen werden. Also es war da schon irgendwie in in diesem typischen brachialen Fordschernanalonus Humor waren halt auch irgendwie so Hitler Anspielungen dabei und das ist.
Äh das heißt so so schlecht war die Ermittlungsmethode der Polizei dann doch gar nicht.
Eher so da in in dem Punkt verstehe ich auch wie ich das dann wusste fand ich's auch nicht mehr so so bedenklich, dass sie nach Ideologie fragen, ja.
Ist der eine Punkt, wo wo das Sinn macht. Aber man muss auch sagen, ähm
wie gesagt, hier, wir haben hier auch keinen CSC und Response bei Hacking, das ist auch nicht so bekannt. In Österreich befürchte ich, dass man da irgendwie großflächig äh die persönlichen Daten von Polizisten oder von irgendjemandem raushaut, ist natürlich auch nicht okay.
Ja, Thomas, super, vielen Dank. Da haben wir jetzt mal äh einen umfangreichen,
Einblick äh bekommen, wie es so in den anderen deutschsprachigen Ländern äh zugeht, zumindest ein Teil, vielleicht sollte man auch irgendwann nochmal einen Blick in die Schweiz wagen, fällt mir dabei gerade mal so äh,
auf.
Wer uns was aus der Schweiz erzählen möchte, der äh melde sich doch einfach mal bei uns. Wer wer Lust hat unser Gast zu sein. Ich hoffe, jetzt kille ich nicht deine Inbox Tim, ähm aber es wäre wäre doch sehr schön.
In der Innenbox liegt ich schon nur noch mit letztem Zuckung irgendwie auf dem Boden. Da kann sich jetzt nicht mehr sehr viel ändern.
Genau oder ähm ihr wendet euch, was weiß ich, per D äh per Tweet, DM direkt an mich äh at und äh oder an AdmE Unterstrich Netzpolitik.
Auch mal drauf hinweisen, genau.
Das sind die beiden. Das ist mein Twitter. Tim, du twitterst auch, glaube ich, oder? Ich auch.
Twitter auch ein bisschen ab und zu und Zeit zu Zeit. Man muss diesen neuen Technologien auch eine Chance geben.
Exakt exakt. Und äh sonst äh Weibertier ist auch noch gut und Ackerfuhr, aber das verlinken wir alles.
Das verlinken wir alles. Äh Schweizer bitte ähm ansonsten suche ich mir einen aus oder eine und fliege.
Oh jane Frau.
Wir machen das einfach dann auch auf schweizerisch.
Immer wir es machen, jetzt bringen wir hier glaube ich das Ding erstmal zu Ende, weil das war jetzt mal, glaube ich, ganz nachhaltig hier äh eine etwas längere Sendung, als wir das hier so üblicher machen. Äh üblicherweise tun, aber äh ich denke, das war jetzt auch ganz angemessen.
Ja, haben wir noch irgendwie? Gibt's noch letzte Grußbotschaften an die Welt? Nein? Dann,
Das jetzt hier zu Ende. Vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Das war die siebzehnte Ausgabe von Lookbuch Netzpolitik. Hoffentlich geht's nächste Woche weiter. Wir schauen mal und äh ja, bis bald.
Bis bald. Tschau, tschau.
Tschau, tschau.